foreign
hey you guys welcome back to flickers of
fear my movie review series
so
2022's skinamarink this was easily one
of my top five most anticipated movies
to see this year
um if you're curious actually the other
four are knock at the cabin which is
based on a Paul Tremblay novel that I
really liked uh infinity pool the
Brandon Cronenberg one um Renfield and
The Voyage of the Demeter so those are
the other four but skinamarink was
actually the first one that I finally
got to lay my eyeballs on because
shutter if you have it just added
skinamarink uh to their streaming
service I think on February 2nd or
something like that I guess it did kind
of like a brief theatrical run I don't
know if it played around here or not
because we don't really get to the
theater that much anymore
um but apparently like it did really
well like it made over a million dollars
like even though the budget was only
fifteen thousand dollars so it was
financially very successful but yeah if
you have shutter uh you can ABS at least
in the United States you can absolutely
watch it uh on there as of February 2nd
but all I knew about this one really was
that the movie had gotten massive
amounts of Buzz online like especially
on Tick Tock I remember like seeing a
lot of people like talking about it on
there what ended up happening was that
the movie debuted at the Fantasia film
festival and then because of some
technical up it actually got leaked
online so a lot of people actually got
to see it before it actually came out
now pretty much the only things I was
aware of was that there was a big buzz
about it
that the audience reaction to the movie
was very very polarized which is usually
like intriguing for me because I really
like movies that people either love them
or hate them like because to me that
seems like it's going to be more
interesting because if everyone's just
kind of like oh is that right you know
what I mean that it's probably not all
that exciting but if if people are
having really extreme reactions to it
then it's obviously probably worth
watching
um but I did manage to avoid any kind of
spoilers or reviews or anything like
that prior to getting to watch it for
myself so I could come into it with as
few preconceptions about it as possible
I didn't even watch the trailer or
anything like that which is the way that
I kind of prefer to go about things
um and as usual I'm immensely immensely
glad that I didn't really know that much
about this one going in because I found
it a lot more I guess like a lot more
unsettling experience when I didn't
really know what to expect from it now
I'm gonna give a big huge gigantic neon
flashing uh caveat though I really
really hesitate to recommend this movie
to anybody who's very very specific
horror taste I don't know because
skinamarink is experimental as and
I feel like most people who approach it
expecting like a traditional narrative
structure or you know traditional
storytelling beats or something like
that will absolutely be confused angry
and or bored to death with this movie
because really unless you allow yourself
to just completely Vibe with this
movie's
infinitesimally small like narrow band
of purpose I guess you want to call it
that it will seem as though maybe to you
that nothing at all is happening for
like a very large segment of the movies
you know hour and 40 minute run time so
like a slow burn is one thing but this
is another situation entirely so I'm not
saying so I'm just warning people ahead
of time like know what you're getting
into I'm really serious about that like
skinamarink basically
looked at you know uh Mark danielesky's
House of leaves the novel um you know
antrum the deadliest movie ever made
have you seen that uh begotten if you've
seen that uh Michael Snow's wavelength
if anybody's seen that one which is just
like several hours of just a camera
going up to a window
um David Lynch's inland empire
particularly the part of it that's uh
rabbits like the short like the weird
little uh sitcom that's in there with
the rabbit head people
this movie kind of looked at all those
movies and was like oh you think you're
inscrutable you think you've actually
captured like an actual human Nightmare
On Film hold my beer because I'm
about to tell you because I'm about to
show you what inscrutability and like
capturing an actual nightmare actually
looks like so that's kind
of where this movie is at so what I'm
saying is that if you like any of the
movies that I just mentioned and also
especially if you're really into kind of
args or like analog type of horror you
know it's you know where something is
like old Tech if you're into that kind
of stuff then skinamarink should be
right up your alley
um you do have to be very patient with
it and open to what it's trying to do
because it's really trying to replicate
a very very particular feeling a very
particular experience that apparently a
lot of people have had so go into it
like knowing that that's what it's doing
now for everybody else uh if you just
like traditional horror if you just like
you know just a regular narrative style
I would advise staying far far away
because you'll probably really really
hate this I really dug it but I
understand uh why you might not you know
what I mean it's just it's subjective
again
um I would also recommend even though I
would usually recommend because like I
said this is a very independent
filmmaker so I would usually uh Advocate
hey like go to the theater and support
it I really think though that for
maximum effectiveness of this movie I
think it's probably better not to see it
in a theater because I think there'd be
too many people or too many distractions
I think the best way to watch this movie
actually is just completely alone in
your house in the middle of the night
like and your house should be like
completely pitch black like as dark as
you can make it just sit up in the
middle of the night and watch this no
other distractions no other people
around no nothing and then after you
watch it you should make your way back
to your bedroom without turning any
lights on you know you can use a
flashlight or something like that if you
want and then when you get in your room
just lay there in your bed in the dark
with your eyes open and just keep
staring out at like the shadowed corners
of the room and just think about the
movie you just watched I think yeah I
think if you do that it's like a whole
it's a whole experience it's a whole
vibe and I think that that would
probably be like the most effective way
to scare yourself shitless like with
this movie okay so to get a feel of what
you're in for matter of fact and to uh
gauge
whether this movie would be something
that you would enjoy go to a YouTube
channel which is actually made by the
director of skinamarink this is his
first feature-length film but he made
short films before this and his name is
Kyle Edward ball
and he has a channel called bite-sized
nightmares
and he basically produces short films
trying to replicate people's nightmares
that they've described to him
um there are several on there that are
only a few minutes long like four or
five minutes something like that but
there's also one called heck which is
about 28 29 minutes long and um that was
like the proof of concept kind of like
preparation short for skinamarink so the
idea for skinamarink uh came out of this
YouTube Project what Kyle ball was
trying to do
was that he started to notice like when
people were sending him like
descriptions of their childhood
nightmares or stuff that had um stuck
with them like over the years he started
to notice that many people's
um nightmares particularly from their
childhood had very similar themes or
very similar imagery in it so it seemed
like he was kind of curious to see if he
could tap into this sort of like Primal
half-remembered like childhood dream
state that maybe we all collectively
share
so I think he actually really um kind of
nailed it with skinamarink which came
across to me as just very very
familiar like it's it was just kind of
mesmerizing it was just kind of like
this spooky it just gives you this whole
sensation and I think and it's not just
me because I kind of feel like a lot of
other people
um it also reminded them too of like
creepy nightmares they had had as
children well hell not even as children
because I was watching this movie I was
like holy I still have nightmares
like this now you know what I mean but I
think like people will remember
um when they watch it
feeling like this particularly as a
child you know what I mean I think it's
like an experience and a feeling that a
lot of people can relate to which I
think is why a lot of people are talking
about it so skinamarink is like one of
the nightmare shorts that's on that
channel but it's like more Lo-Fi and
extended out to like an hour and 40
minutes also the house he shot
skinamarink in which is actually his
childhood home uh which you know we'll
get into that a little bit in a minute
but that house that same house like also
appears in all the other shorts that
I've watched on that channel I haven't
watched them all but like the ones that
I watched that he uses the same house
you know what I mean so the plot of this
movie if you want to call it that I mean
I really don't but I don't really know
how else to put it
it concerns two children uh six-year-old
Kaylee and four-year-old Kevin uh you
know obviously their brother and sister
the year is 1995 that's when this is set
now the kids are apparently in the house
with their parents or at least their dad
but keep in mind that throughout pretty
much the entire running time you don't
really see anyone in the movie
at all like you kind of do but you never
see anybody like full-on or you never
really see anybody's face full on or
anything like that and it's not just
because the whole movie is very very
dark and it's the way that shot is like
super super grainy
most of the time the kids who are like
the main characters if you want to say
that
um they're kind of off screen like
you're generally seeing things from
their perspective so everything is from
like a child's uh you know Viewpoint so
everything's kind of like down closer to
the floor
um you see their legs and feet sometimes
you know you see you know the side of
someone's face you see like the back of
their head something like that
so the mother and father are seen even
less
um and they're usually seen from the
back particularly the mom
um and that is something I think I
brought this up before but that's
something that's always weirded me out
in horror movies just seeing the back of
someone's head for some reason that's
like really creepy so I think that one
of the reasons that I liked this movie
so much is that it seemed almost
particularly I mean very tailored to my
own very weird and very idiosyncratic
you know creep buttons I guess if you
want to call them that like I'm very
very creeped out by like just going into
a room and like just seeing someone
sitting there like the back of their
head and they don't turn around or
anything like that creeps me out
um seeing someone's face like with some
of their features removed uh that
happens in this as well so this seemed
like very very calculated
to kind of push those particular buttons
like this that creep me out you know
what I mean so it's very very good at
doing that so it really did a number on
me in that regard because there's a lot
of that kind of stuff going on in this
so there are some hints like near the
beginning of the movie that the boy
Kevin has had some kind of accident and
has maybe fallen down the stairs like
perhaps while he was sleepwalking
but his dad tells someone on the phone
maybe the mom we're not entirely sure
who he's talking to
but he says oh the kid's pretty much
fine like you know he went to the
hospital but he didn't even need
stitches but like his head is messed up
or something like that
now soon after this event the children
apparently wake up
in their dark ass house in the middle of
the night I'm assuming
and they discovered that not only have
their parents
evidently disappeared from the house
entirely
but also the children themselves are
unable to leave the house because all
the doors and windows are Vanishing
um like there's a scene where Kevin
pulls up the blinds like you know
Venetian blinds and there's just like a
solid wall behind them like there's kind
of a thing where they go down the hall
and there's like a door and then it just
like disappears and then it's just a
blank wall so the kids are trapped in
this house in the middle of the night
their parents are gone and now they
can't get out so unsure of what to do
they're not that's what I think is like
really great about this because the kids
don't
panic I mean they're four and six like
they seem to know that something is
wrong and it's like kind of scary but
they don't really seem to grasp how
weird or how Monumental the situation is
or how much danger they might
potentially be in they seem like very
unsettled like oh you know that's kind
of weird but much like a an actual kid
would they can't really wrap their heads
you know because they're children so
they can't really wrap their heads
around you know if an adult like if that
happened to an adult you would be
freaking the out because you would
know how strange that was but
because kids are I guess in some ways
they they don't really understand the
gravity of the situation and they also
don't you know like I said they can't
really wrap their head around how
bizarre it is because kids are just more
open to you know weird experiences
because they don't have enough
experience of the world to like know how
how not right that is so they're
unsettled but they're not terrified you
know what I mean so they're just trying
to kind of like deal with things isn't
the best way that a kid would deal with
them
so they don't really know what to do
they kind of creep downstairs to the
living room and turn on the TV because
that's you know I guess that's kind of
soothing and they put like some cartoons
on so most of the movie has this really
strange
immersive atmosphere that I kind of feel
like many of us might remember like from
being a child and being up way past our
bedtimes like the house is like really
quiet except for this just kind of
distant music and voices from like these
old like weird cartoons
um the only light in the house is this
blue flicker from like the old CRT
screen and you know they build like a
little kind of pillow for it they have
like a little couch that they kind of
push inside because it makes them feel
like safer like they're kind of like
Walling themselves off they bring down
their stuffed animals and their Legos
and everything like that so like I said
they're they're kind of like making a
little protective bubble they don't
really know what else to do because
they're just like children
so a lot of the movie's run time is
concerned with just these types of
experiences so there's just these
lingering shots of just like darkened
hallways and doorways where the very
grainy film stock just kind of starts
making your imagination play tricks on
you like it's really encouraging you to
kind of like pick shapes out of the
darkness you know what I mean because
it's very grainy and you're just like is
that a person is that like a shadow like
you can't really tell
um and there's also these kind of like
mysterious and kind of unexplained like
thumps and creaks and stuff like that
like coming from upstairs you don't
exactly know you know what's in the
house who's in the house what's going on
uh the kids also talk only in Whispers
and uh some of the whispers are actually
subtitled now I had the closed
captioning on because I'm deaf as
the thing about it is I would advise it
because sometimes you can't really tell
because some of the voices and stuff
like that are really quiet or they're
really distorted so sometimes you can't
really tell what they're saying because
not everything is subtitled like in the
movie itself like sometimes so I did
have the subtitles on it kind of ruins
the illusion a little bit but I kind of
like that I had it on because I don't
think I would have caught some of the
dialogue and some of the dialogue I
think is
sort of important like to sort of suss
out what exactly is going on in this I
have to say too like the sound design in
general here is also goes a long way
toward making this movie like really
disquieting like to watch because like I
said there's just kind of Whispers and
these distant distorted voices that are
interspersed with just occasional kind
of ominous tones like these just weird
Sinister sounding tones in the
background and then there's also like
these kind of very sudden jarring
shrieks which kind of like accompany
this pretty upsetting like flashes of
imagery so there's kind of like jump
scares kind of um going through there
with this like a really loud noise and
then something like Cuts away so there's
that kind of stuff going on there too so
as the movie goes on like ever more
bizarre things start to take place in
the house like for example like you kind
of get sort of like Poltergeist activity
kind of like the a chair like they hear
a thump and then all of a sudden this
chair which had been like sitting in the
kitchen is now like on the ceiling which
that freaked me the out like
like that like freaks me the out
because it's like not not overt like
it's not overtly horror like blah it's a
demon or anything like that but it's
just like little like that where
something is just wrong like everything
else is normal but then all of a sudden
the chair is like oh now the chair is on
the ceiling now like that to me that
sort of like um
this that incongruity is like really
really creepy to me so a lot of the
stuff in this movie like really like I
said really did a number on me because
this is like it seemed specifically
tailored to like my own weird things
that creep me out you know what I mean
so yeah so you got like a chair going up
on the ceiling like toys and like other
objects kind of disappear and then like
they'll re reappear in like very uncanny
like configurations like now they're all
stuck to the wall or something like that
um the cartoons on the TV like kind of
start pausing and like looping over and
over
and then you start hearing this very
Sinister distorted voice and it starts
trying to lure the children to other
parts of the house like come upstairs or
come down to the basement and eventually
gets to a point where it's kind of
encouraging them to do harm to
themselves I mean one scene in
particular that really
kind of freaks me out and I think a lot
of people because I watched a couple
other reviews of this and a lot of
people brought this scene up
um because it's pretty skin crawling but
it's when Kaylee the little girl she
goes in her parents room I'm presuming
and she sees her father sitting on the
edge of the bed like pretty much all we
see of him is his legs like clad and
pajama pants and he's just like in his
hands which are kind of like gripping
the edge of the bed like that but like I
said it's dark so you can't really see
anyone's face so you can't really see
exactly what's going on
so the implication is they don't say
this outright but the way the movie goes
you're kind of led to assume that this
maybe isn't actually the child's father
but is perhaps this
whatever this thing is that's in the
house like the monster or whatever it is
like maybe pretending that it's the
father that was the impression that I
got
um so the father like essentially like
asked her to look under the bed
and
it's dark in the room and you know it's
just kind of like you remember like back
when you were a little kid and you like
you thought you heard something in the
room and it's like you want to look
under the bed you know and you're
thinking about that scene from
Poltergeist where the kid looks out of
the bed that he comes out there's like
evil clown doll and all that kind of
so it's that kind of so I mean
the next couple minutes after that it's
just this Exquisite exercise and Dread
and it comes from nothing really like
other than our own deeply rooted fears
from childhood and just this suggestive
Darkness that's on the screen in front
of us because you're just like sitting
there on the edge of your seat going
what the is under that bed like
what's gonna pop out in your face
because it's like you know you're in the
perspective of like a little kid who's
like you know leaning down and like
looking under there and it's like
completely black and it's like really
really creepy you know what I mean like
so I think like the genius of this movie
I mean provided that you're willing to
jump on its particular wave and you know
kind of get into what it's trying to do
is that a lot of the scariness of the
film comes from you doing a number on
yourself like your own imagination
because you're just the whole movie it's
so dark and uh you know and it's just so
unclear and just so inscrutable that
every single scene every single shot
you know it's just like a lingering
hallway or a lingering room and like
these dark corners and so your brain is
just kind of like feverishly like
searching this ever-shifting you know
very grainy Blackness for these terrible
things that you probably know are in
there somewhere you know what I mean so
it's really your imagination like doing
a number on yourself and and you really
like this whole movie I kind of it
really makes you feel like this is just
some weird that you stumbled across
like on an old unmarked videotape in
someone's attic or some like that
like something you're not really
supposed to be watching like something
that shouldn't have been recorded to
start with like where the did this
come from like some From Another
Dimension or something like that's not
to say that it's particularly graphic or
gory or I don't want to say it's not
disturbing because the implications of
it are disturbing but it's not like real
overt like it's not showing you a lot of
violence or up or anything
like that but the movie just feels like
off or it feels like wrong somehow like
almost like it kind of like leeched out
of somebody's subconscious and like
imprinted itself on tape like that
creepy from The Ring you know what
I mean except like feature length so I I
will say there are some interesting
interpretations like floating around on
the internet of what exactly is going on
in this movie or like what this movie
means like if somebody want to explain
it or something because I will say that
despite the non-traditional narrative or
the non-traditional way that it's
presented there is clearly something
happening there is clearly some kind of
story going on behind it some kind of
symbolism some kind of you know what I
mean but it's just not holding your hand
and telling you exactly what it is and I
think to a large extent
um this movie will be a subjective
experience for everyone like everyone's
gonna kind of interpret it um maybe
through the lens of their own childhood
perhaps I definitely personally got the
impression that the children's mother
who you only see a couple of times is
perhaps divorcing the father I get the
feeling that she was perhaps probably
abusive and I kind of also got the
feeling that she might be the actual
Catalyst for whatever the supernatural
monster or demon or whatever it is
that's in the house that's like trapped
them inside like trapped them in this
time Loop essentially which you know is
apparently endless like it's it's almost
kind of like this purgatorial Loop like
they're trapped inside because there's
you know images of like a doll house and
things like that so it's almost kind of
like these kids are trapped in this
endless loop of you know abuse or
violence or something like that whether
or not the the demon is real I kind of
my interpretation of it was that the
mother was
the was the monster I guess you know
what I mean or or had invited the
monster there somehow like I you know
but you know there's other
interpretations but that's kind of like
what I got from it
um it actually seems significant that
Kyle Edward ball the director I saw like
an interview with him like where he was
talking about skinamarink and he
mentioned
Hansel and Gretel
uh which seemed you know that seemed
very significant he also said that the
film was partially autobiographical like
he was trying to convey a particular
feeling that he and his sister had
because he has a little bit older sister
as well uh that they had when they were
children dealing what with whatever was
happening in their own house and with
their own parents and like I said so
it's also significant that he shot this
in the house that he and his sister grew
up in so he's definitely trying to take
his own experiences of him and his
sister being little kids and being
scared in their dark house or thinking
they're alone or something like that and
he's trying to put that on film and see
if other people like kind of resonate
with the same feeling that I got and
like I said I think that he's largely
been successful in doing that because
watching this movie I really got I
remembered what that was like like when
you were a little kid and like you wake
up in the middle of the night and it's
like pitch black and you think nobody's
in there or you think you see something
in the corner this is very very good at
conveying that very very specific
feeling so as I mentioned um you know
this is absolutely not a film for
everyone but it really does seem like
it's resonating hard like with a large
chunk of the horror movie fandom who
again like understand the sensations
that it's trying to convey like the
Nostalgia the like a little bit of a
nostalgic feeling that childhood trauma
that this movie is attempting to
replicate now when I first started
watching this I wasn't actually sure if
I was gonna enjoy it once I kind of like
saw what it was doing
um I'm actually not proud of this and I
don't usually do this but when I first
put it on I was actually watching it on
my laptop like over here like on one eye
and then I had my other computer like in
front of me like that and I was like
working on something else so I kept like
glancing over watching it after about 10
or 15 minutes though like I just got
hypnotized kind of like by the movie so
I just abandoned whatever work I was
doing over here and then just like laser
focus right on the the movie and it
really kind of weaves this very creepy
like bizarre spell over you if you let
it do that and like I said if it doesn't
resonate with you that's uh you know
that's obviously legitimate too because
not everybody's you know horror is very
subjective and some people are really
gonna get it and some people are just
kind of like and I'll get it or I get
what they were going for but I don't
think they were successful you know what
I mean so I'm not saying that everybody
has to like this and if you don't then
you didn't get it or whatever but you
know it's gonna be a specific kind of
person that really gets into it and I
really really got into it it's to me it
seemed very mesmerizing and I
immediately like remembered feeling the
way he was trying to make me feel you
know what I mean so yeah I mean whether
you love it or hate it I mean you really
can't deny that this movie is doing
something wildly different and it's
trying a new approach and you know I
think that's why I will always love
horror it's like forever innovating it's
all you know it's a certain portion of
it is always yeah because there's always
going to be knockoffs and things like
that but I kind of feel like you know
out in the fringes of horror there's
always going to be people that are
always innovating looking for new ways
to scare people like looking for new
ways to get past the like the chinks in
people's armor like to really get them
where they live so like I said if
skinamarink didn't particularly work for
you I mean maybe something else will but
I definitely think in general it's good
to support independent and especially
really experimental horror like this
because I think it's the best way to
keep horror you know to keep the genre
really fresh and keep it scary and like
I said even if you didn't like this
particular movie you know maybe the next
person that comes along the next
independent person that gets a chant
because this one did well you know maybe
that one will resonate with you like
more than this one did so I think it's
good to like support this kind of stuff
even if you didn't particularly resonate
with it but I really liked this one a
lot
um and it really made me feel
a way that I haven't felt in a long time
you know what I mean which that's really
a pretty awesome experience in itself so
so that will do it for this flickers of
here hope you enjoyed it remember to
like share and comment if you enjoyed
the video and I'll see you guys again on
the next one
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]